[Applause]
[Music]
Usher and ET have teamed up to give you
this hot exclusive I hope you ready for
this Usher there's a reason they call
him Mr
entertainment that was a performance of
a Lifetime right did from his chart
topping
success
yeah starting when he was just a
teen Grandma I made it to taking on the
Super Bowl stage this is a celebration
of my legacy my music of my passion what
you never knew about this multi-talented
Superstar singer actor dancer CEO oh my
God we'll take you to the set of his
music
videos we're hot and movies got to be
plus how he became the king of Las
Vegas there is a very intimate scene uh
that's for the ladies this is ET Vault
unlocked for Applause that's ultimate
entertainment 18 top 10 hits the hottest
residency in all of Vegas and soon Usher
will make Super Bowl Halftime history
welcome to Entertainment Tonight yeah
man to see how far Mr entertainment has
come we're going to unlock where Usher
has been peace
up this is a celebration of uh of my
legacy it's a celebration of my music
[Music]
it's a celebration of my passion 30
years ago that Journey started and and
now it's landed me at this point in my
life at the super bow et's been on that
Journey with Usher from his first hits
to his eight Grammy wins to his spot on
Hollywood's Walk of Fame I realized in
order to be an ultimate Entertainer you
have to have all of the above as an
actor as a singer as a dancer as a
producer as a poet as a musician all of
those things so with Super Bowl Sunday
what can we expect to work words hit
records the set list has been hard you
know the hardest part what's that 13
minutes you got yet too many songs in
too few minutes you got 13 minutes in
order to get through an entire Legacy of
uh of Music are you already filling
phone calls from the friends and folks
that you've collaborated with over the
years you maybe a little Alicia maybe a
little
Bieber I've been considering a lot us
your's other collabs include Lil John
and ludicrous take that and Rewind it
back and most recently Kiki
[Music]
Palmer Usher's February 11th halftime
show which airs live on CVS won't be his
first time on the Super Bowl field Kevin
talked to him back in 2011 after he was
a guest of the blackeyed peas how
incredible was that that was a
performance of a Lifetime right there
Usher will drop his first new solo album
in seven years on the same day as the
Super Bowl his headliner strategy study
the all stars I got a long list of
people who have done this and did it
right Michael did it right Beyonce did
it right Prince did it right I'm a
praying man and I'm really really
humbled that I have this opportunity I'm
trying to figure out how to entertain
people make certain that they understand
the Legacy enjoy the moment and make
certain that they have a show that
they'll never
[Music]
forget this is a moment that I've waited
my entire life for and I am not coming
to disappoint Usher spot on the biggest
stage in the world is a far cry from his
humble upbringing in Chattanooga
Tennessee his first taste of music was
his church choir directed by his mom
Jetta Patton my mother's always one of
the best for me as an artist and the
best for her child there were so many
non-believers but I was always there in
his corner to really believe in him
because he is the star he he is a star
he was a star then and he's a star now
when his family moved to Atlanta at age
12 he began performing in local talent
shows I always wanted to be uh the best
at everything that I did you know I was
the kind of kid that you know always
wanted the most attention so I would go
over and Beyond to make sure that I got
it rather it was danc and singing and
that actually just turned into my talent
and the thing that I love to do the most
it wasn't long before Usher caught the
attention of record executive LA Reid
who signed him at 14 years old got up
and he performed and he mesmerized
people I don't know it was just
something really magical about him from
the very beginning you got to work hard
if you want to make it in this business
you have to be willing to make the
sacrifices that come with it you have to
be willing to put the work
[Music]
in if you really want to know the
history go back get the first album
executive produced by Puff Daddy La
[Music]
Reed Diddy then known as Puff Daddy
produced Usher's first self-titled album
it achieved moderate success I met puffy
a long time ago um around 92 I went out
to meet him he was a really cool cat he
was just getting started badway was you
know really up and coming 3 years later
he hooked up with Germaine dpri for his
second album my way that's when he
became a
[Music]
superstar the best part of this year has
been the fact that I can do finally what
I wanted to do and people you know
respect it his breakout album not only
earned respect but his single you make
me want to scored Usher's first Grammy
nomination also the Man the ride is is
ridiculous um in between receiving
bottles of D PE from Elon John and
getting Grammys man that that's that's
just
overwhelming um well you know I'm
excited I'm excited to uh you know even
be nominated so I mean if I win I win if
I done I done Usher didn't bring home
the gold but 1998 had plenty of wins
this is cool this is the Soul Train
Music Awards of
1998 best R&B soul yall remember this
day hardest of the Year
hey the next year ET caught the exact
moment Usher learned about his second
Grammy nod on camera W Grandma I made it
no my way started because I found out
about Frank anatra and then I found this
song my way I was like oh that's that's
how I feel right now Usher's other
Inspirations Prince James Brown and
Michael Jackson who we got to perform
with back in
2001 when I when I caught the news I
would I just had a little silent moment
to myself I even cried I even lie you
know because uh Michael Jackson is the
reason why I do what I do MJ's influence
was evident in ushers You Remind Me
music video The 8701 hit that finally
earned the R&B star his first
[Music]
grm Usher and ET have teamed up to give
you this hot exclusive I hope you ready
for
this users Mega hit yeah toed the charts
for 3 months in 2004 that's a huge
reason his album confessions took home
Grammy gold I'm ecstatic right now cuz
I've won two Grammys best rap
collaboration as well as best duo with
Alicia Keys my boo so we got two Grammys
tonight already I'm already have one of
the hottest tracks my boo with Alicia
Keys ET was exclusive on the music video
set in Time
Square very romantic especially I think
it comes at the right time because it's
really what do you mean we're hot oh
that's it right
there but confessions was hotly debated
among fans many speculated that several
of the album's hits burn and Confessions
Part two were about his then
relationship with TLC's Chile I feel
like this is coming to an end oh my god
look who's here Chile's
here your girl hey
girl how are th yeah I'm I'm cool I'm
cool Chile is the jam she understands
what I go through understand the
sacrifices that I have to make in order
to be who I
am I never knew what to expect man you
know all I did was go in the studio and
came up with some really great stories
some that I lived out and um it turned
out to be really great it was a
collection of great energy everybody was
very positive you know every album you
get you gain a little bit more you know
of a team or or an enthusiasm Chile has
always denied this songs are about her
but as you'd expect the gossip only
helped confession sold more than 18
million copies three records in in the
top 10 there's not many people who can
do that in fact it hadn't been done for
more than 25 years Usher toured to
support the album A young Kanye West was
his opening act and Usher gave ET an
exclusive backstage pass well what we
have here is all of my wardrobe this is
all custom made right here as you see it
you know I know sometime I can be a
little
excessive you know maybe having aund
pairs of jeans just isn't enough
[Music]
okay okay we know he lives for fashion
but he's also the new king of Vegas by
the Numbers Usher has had two Vegas
residencies and reportedly made around a
million each night earlier this month
Usher was emotional as he closed out 100
shows but more than a decade ago he
predicted Vegas is where he'd win big
Vegas is intended to give people an
experience of a
fantasy Vegas is more for the experience
it's a little bit more intimate uh a
little bit more up close and personal
that up close and personal experience is
exactly what brought out all the stars
I'm going to get together the most fun
group and we are going to go see
[Music]
Usher watch what happened when Usher
serated Kim
K then there's Jessica Alba
oh DOA cat grooved and joined in singing
the
[Music]
lyrics Usher's 2-hour shows could be a
clue on what we can expect from his
Super Bowl performance happening live
February 11th on CBS their sexy dance
moves flirting with fans and
this my favorite thing thus far is the
skating
but it's his Decades of hits that really
bring the fans and a-listers to his Sin
City experience these songs they they're
kind of a part of us growing
up there is a very intimate scene that's
for the ladies it gets a little frisky
other stars showing out for Usher Kiki
Palmer JLo Zena and Tom Holland and
Queen Latifa there's nothing negative
that's happening in Las Vegas other than
a good time people decided to come out
be sophisticated for the night dress in
their best and uh enjoy the night and
that's what I hope that they continue to
do ARA
[Music]
baby my mother's dream a long time ago
was to definitely get me out as an
Entertainer uh first first and foremost
as a singer then mve into other aspects
of acting of entertainment acting ushers
mom's Dream came true when he made his
acting debut in 1997 guest starring on
moisha Jeremy thank you for taking me to
the concert you know I love Usher he all
right I've seen people like Elvis
Presley do it so hey why can't us you do
it next up a soap opera I got a call
from you know the B beautiful which was
you know just an introduction to me it
really showed me that there's some space
for growth and entertainment for me so
uh when I got the opportunity to you
know get on the big screen I jumped at
it Usher made his film debut in the
faculty and in 1998 I'm really uh the
football player you know the football
captain SL badass you know what I mean
sure you don't want to play with us and
remember when he played the DJ and she's
all that okay everybody R SE coming into
the business Marvin Gay was definitely
one of the people I had a lot I've
always wanted to play Marin gay Usher
would get his wish in 202 playing the
late singer in episode of American
Dreams
you always have to expand I mean I've
always told every person that I've ever
come in contact with that I'm in this
for the
longevity Usher did expand to Broadway
when he made his debut as Billy Flynn in
Chicago 7 years later he took on The
Voice man I mean why not you know when
the opportunity presents itself if it's
something that's incredible you go for
it I'm going to do my best to win he
didn't win that season but two seasons
later Josh cofin wins it for team
Usher I mean what hasn't this guy done
now when it comes to Usher's biggest and
most important role well that's being a
dad I think the greatest Pastime for me
is the time with my children and it
makes it all worthwhile you know I
obviously have my career and uh my dad
time that's like the greatest
man yes Mr entertainment's favorite role
is data four he has two sons with his
first wife Tama Foster we watch
16-year-old Cino and 15-year-old naid
grow up Usher told me he's a Hands-On
Dad don't trip every 30 minutes I'm
calling a nanny to make sure that we
having a PP break are you yeah we got to
do that yeah when Usher was on his third
world tour he took the boys with him as
much as possible they have their own
play area you know here in the in the
venue do you see any uh Little Junior
performers in them coming out if they
decide to ever you know go in the
direction of entertainment music of
course I'd be supportive and I'll be I'd
be one of the greatest coaches ever to
him and a great
mentor now Navid is acting as his mentor
helping with his Super Bowl playlist
he's giving me tons of notes giving me
tons of ideas you he loves concerts so
um you know the ideas are just flowing
he's giving me his set list okay how
much time I should spend on certain
songs Usher's busy balancing life with
teens and toddlers more than 12 years
after the birth of his oldest son Usher
and his girlfriend music exek Jen guoa
became parents to a baby girl Sovereign
Bo who he calls rainbow well first of
all her first word was Dad Dad that's
the coolest right is it not it wasn't
long before rainbow became a big sis she
is just one year older than her baby
brother sire what does that mean to you
that so many people look up to you as a
father I mean I I appreciate it you know
I'm not doing it for the approval but
I'm doing it uh as a conscious reminder
that you know father should you know
really really spend the time with their
children given the fact that I didn't
have a father my father wasn't there uh
it makes it even more uh of a pleasure
to be able to be there for my kids from
his personal life to his personal style
ushers had a fashion
Evolution best dressed you know to the
11s oh man that's killing them you doing
your thing man I do all my spare time as
a little hobby you know I design
clothes
this is Usher Raymond for the evening
this suit was designed by myself this is
Rock and Soul that I'm introducing to
you it's a twing of fashion a little bit
of this little
bit I'm I'm really a black on black on
black guy and it'll be full of
accessories maybe nice cuff Lings a nice
ring
earrings how many carrots are we wearing
tonight Usher too many enough to lose
count music and fashion have always gone
hand in
[Music]
hand
in the '90s it was the stocking cap for
the fresh waves but by the early 2000s
Usher went from his signature beanie to
the Atlanta Braves Snapback setting a
trend you got one two
three me see oh God man four five 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 just just keeps
going obviously I see that you know my
style has been downloaded I see a lot of
cats out here whove definitely redubbed
what we've already done that was
yesterday's news today is you know
simply sexy let me show you how it's
which simply means showing off that
six-pack which helped him land on
People's sexiest men list back in 2004
obviously the girls love the uh the
watch boy
ABS that's a part of my uh Mojo you it's
the star power you know when I take my
shirt off obviously all the girls they
go crazy
and uh the sexiness of it how do I feel
about all that um oh hey how you doing
um I work hard
to I need you to get ready and don't
tell anybody you received this call man
that promo still gives me chill so good
but when Usher takes the Super Bowl
Halftime stage we won't only hear the
hits no ushers bring it all home with
new music his new album coming home
drops the same day can't wait for that
take
care you know really excited you know
for this ninth album uh to release man a
lot of people been asking when are you
going to drop this thing uh it's
time you're coming to the Super Bowl and
you're also coming home on February 11th
it's coming all coming home this is a
celebration of uh of my legacy my music
my passion lot of songs lot of moments
lot of Dan lot of energy I tried a few
new things work with some new producers
producers that I've worked with in the
past La working with LA Reed as a
partner so that's part of the reason
that I named it coming home this 30
years of an evolution has now brought me
back
[Music]
home